la réforme que nous présentons est
d'abord une réforme soucieuse de justice
travailler plus longtemps oui mais pas
pour tout le monde et pas de la même
manière nous allons conserver et
améliorer le dispositif des carrières
longues en le rendant plus juste plus
lisible en élargissant aussi aux
périodes de congé parental nous
apportons également une réponse au
carrières très longues en permettant au
travailleur et ont commencé à avoir 18
ans de partir quatre ans avant l'âge
légal nous le faisons en préservant les
dispositifs déjà prévus pour soyons
débuter avant 20 ans et si vous
l'acceptez bien sûr nous vous proposons
d'inclure ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler avant 21 ans comme l'a évoqué
la première ministre devant l'Assemblée
nationale ces améliorations ne pourront
pas pour autant dénaturer le système
dans le principe fondamental et que la
durée de cotisation est un minimum un
plancher sans jamais avoir été un
plafond nous vous proposons un système
plus juste qui est aussi un système qui
prend mieux en compte les travailleurs
les plus fragiles les victimes
d'accident et maladies professionnelles
ainsi les travailleurs handicapés
pourront toujours partir à la retraite à
55 ans et les travailleurs invéliers
d'où il n'a percevons toujours une
retraite plutôt plein des 62 ans comme
aujourd'hui dans le même temps
maintenant le dispositif de départ
anticipé à 50 ans pour les salariés
exposés à l'amiante avec ce texte nous
vous proposons aussi de mettre à profit
cette opportunité pour compléter les
lois dechassen du nom du président du
groupe communiste à l'Assemblée
nationale en particulier la première en
considérant comme complète la carrière
des exploitants agricoles qui auraient
été interrompu avant son terme pour une
aptitude ou invalidité cette condition
d'une carrière complète et que c'est
exigée pour bénéficier de la pension
minimale et l'aménagement proposé dans
ce texte permettra ainsi à 45 45 000
exploitants à la retraite de plus d'en
bénéficier avec une revalorisation
d'environ 80 euros par mois
concernant les aidons nous créons une
assurance vieillesse pour les aidants
qui viendra compenser les interruptions
de carrière par l'attribution de droits
de nouveaux et nous veillons ainsi à
tenir compte des particularités des
parcours comme de la difficulté des
métiers exercés nous voulons aussi avec
cette réforme crée de nouveaux droits et
faire de cette réforme une réforme de
progrès vous entendons donc améliorer la
prise en compte de la pénibilité et
notamment l'usure liée aux conditions
d'exercice de certains métiers l'accès
les droits acquis avec le compte
professionnel des prévention seront
considérablement renforcés avec un
abaissement des seuils avec une
meilleure prise en compte des
polyexposés avec la création de nouveaux
de nouvelles utilisations possibles
comme un congé de reconversion afin
d'éviter l'enfermement dans des métiers
difficiles sans perdre en rémunération
nous demanderons aussi aux bronches de
négocier des accords de prévention
l'usure professionnelle pour les métiers
identifiés comme difficiles par les
instances de la sécurité sociale
notamment la branche à TMP afin de tenir
compte de l'exposition aux critères
ergonomique de part de charge lourdes de
posture pénible ou de vibrations et pour
accompagner ce suivi pour financer les
mesures des accords de prévention
nous créerons un fond d'investissement
dans la prévention l'usure
professionnelle doté d'un milliard
d'euros sur les cinq prochaines années
[Musique]